welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Gordon jabal associate dean of alumni
and external affairs and lecturer in
urban ecology at Yale School of Forestry
and environmental studies he is
interested in sustainability issues that
are faced by small island developing
states today we'll talk with him about
Haiti and sustainable development in a
post disaster context welcome professor
jabal great to be here thanks for having
me so you teach a special graduate
course with some other folks here at
Yale particularly about Haiti and the
issues there so why don't you give us an
overview of it okay so this course
started just after the earthquake in
2010 when port-au-prince the capital of
Haiti was pretty much leveled and the
students here at Yale graduate students
especially at the school forestry mental
studies and at public health said we
should be doing more in Haiti than just
sending money of the Red Cross
Haney's known as the poorest station in
the Western Hemisphere it's one of the
poorest in the world and I think their
instinct was were special people we've
got this great education we have all
these resources here shouldn't we be in
doing more than just sort of waving our
cigarette lighters and giving a couple
dollars and then going back to our
studies okay so it took me a while but I
found I doctor at the Medical School
gary dizzier who's Haitian and he and I
have caught of course this will the
spring will be our fourth version of it
and it's a practicum course we study
projects in Haiti and we go to Haiti
over spring break for about 10 days the
whole class about 20 of us 16 students
and four staff and we're working with
l'hopital albert schweitzer
which is a hospital north of
port-au-prince about two hours okay and
our goal is to not do projects this is
something we might want to get into I'm
very interested in the word help how do
you help somebody
we don't do projects we better version
of it is that we're a consultancy okay
so we're there to listen to them observe
what they do listen to what their
problems are and then try to make
suggestions to them as to where they
might proceed where
might be productive for them to move
sometimes we do a little bit of work for
them but most of its it's just
transferring ideas and then of course we
get a lot we get an introduction to
Haiti the beautiful people the culture
the food we get to travel around their
country and have a nice Spring Break and
so let's talk specifics specifically
give us some examples of what you do
talk about in the in the class okay
so although we're associated with a
hospital
we actually don't go down and do any
medical work we work with an
organization called integrated community
services that the hospital set up so the
hospital like many as many hospitals do
notice that many of the people were
coming to them probably sicker than they
should be
in this case mainly because of
malnutrition so if you're malnourished
you're gonna get a cold but it's gonna
be a more serious cold or you're gonna
get cholera and it's gonna be a much
more serious version of cholera so the
hospital said we should go out into the
community and try to help solve this
malnutrition error problem and that's
where we came in so for instance as you
probably know a large amount of the
trees of Haiti have been cut down in the
last 50 years or so especially now as
the populations grown bigger the wood is
used mainly for charcoal in the rural
areas to cook mm-hmm
so we are working with this integrated
Community Services in a field called
agroforestry agroforestry is agriculture
and forestry so plants crops and trees
put together in some kind of fashion so
for instance Agri Forest we can solve
erosion problems much of Haiti is steep
hillside and if you cut the trees down
the roots aren't holding the soil bound
the soil will wash away and it will not
only degrade the farmer's land but it
will then spoil through erosion and
landslides the land down below so by
planting trees you hold the soil in
place so we are the integrated community
services already started an agroforestry
program and we're there to observe it
and help them think through problems so
one of the issues for this semester will
be yams okay one of my favorite desserts
I love them oh great especially as we
approach Thanksgiving here or around
Thanksgiving time
yams are a very nutritious plant and
they can be planted in an area where
there's a little bit more shade so you
can plant them under trees before the
canopy gets totally dark so it's you can
have trees that are growing to hold the
soil back they eventually will be a crop
that you could cut down and sell as
timber so there'll be money for the
farmer but in the meantime you can plant
the yams under the trees and either eat
them or take them to the village to sell
so that's an example of agroforestry
which they've already started and we're
just consulting with them on their
projects ok so now this will be the
fourth or fifth area going this will be
the fourth here so in the course of the
past four years what do you think have
been some of the greater successes ok so
this is a huge problem the word success
ok as you may know in the philanthropic
or foundation world the foundations
increasingly Rask proved to us that when
we give you money to do something that
you're having the desired outcomes but
if you think about it how do we measure
nutrition when we're really talking
about what a child is going to be like 3
or 4 or 5 years from now we don't know
if we really are having the effect so
it's very hard to ask the question if
we're successful the closest I've come
to that is if we come back either next
year or the year after and something
that we talked about is something that
people are doing in the field then I
will feel that we gave an idea that
someone thought was useful and that the
local people are appropriating so as an
example in our very first visit down
there we had a student from the school
public health who had been in the Peace
Corps in Africa and she'd observed
something called a tippy tap which is a
very simple hand washing mechanism that
allows you to wash your hands and the
water they that drips out of a bottle
goes into the soil so when you're
washing your hands it's it's not you're
not using water that someone else is
already used you're not washing in a tub
where your water and then you're washing
your hands and so on and so we
introduced this and there actually have
been a couple more built and the people
are talking about it and it's possible
that it will be a mechanism that well
lasting power in an area where there's
zero running water and water is very
scarce to begin with in the mountains so
since the earthquake I mean I'm not sure
how developed Haiti was prior to the
earthquake was there running water prior
to the earthquake
okay so Haiti's like most other
countries in the world including the
United States in a simple way you can
divide it into an urbanized area and a
rural area so in the urbanized area
there is running water there three-star
hotels four-star hotels there's streets
and you know bars and all everything you
would find in any city when you get to
the rural areas as you would give in the
United States you find very little
almost no piped water and everybody's
getting their water from Springs or from
wells so and and that's another problem
that we've worked on is what's the
quality of the water that's coming out
of those wells so Haiti spent a lot of
time worrying about infectious diseases
and since the earthquake we have Haiti
had the cholera that was introduced and
so washing your hands but the quality of
water used for cooking and and washing
has become a big issue so has have has
there been much improvement over the
over the past three years since since
the earthquake I mean it seems like I
mean it was it seems like a lot of money
got dumped into Haiti so did that make
any kind of difference at all well I
hate to give you a very academic answer
but the answer to that is yes and no so
yes in that new housing is being built
most of people that lived in tents have
left the tents actually cholera was kept
out of the tent city so there's a
phenomenal success because the cholera
came after the earthquake so you had the
earthquake you had so many people move
into these tent cities the cholera came
in a rural area and they were able by
Public Health methods to keep the caller
from getting in
to an area the tent cities where you
would have expected to just run right so
there's been a lot of successes there
was a peaceful election the country is
very stable the three years we've gone
there we've had just a great time very
peaceful no problems so yes and the
answer to know is it's still very poor
the growth national product or any
measure of the economy is still very
very weak the peacekeeping is still done
by an external UN force the Haitians do
not have really their own way of keeping
peace so there's been progress but slow
progress I guess is a positive way to
say it so do you think the course will
continue for several years moving
forward well when I started the course I
said I would do it for five years and
then stop lying
the reason is Haiti is known as the
country of NGOs there are so many
nonprofit organizations many of them
local but most of them us oriented and
there are people that worry that the
culture the economic culture but even
the the literary and artistic culture is
becoming dominated by these external
forces and I didn't want my
participation in Haiti to be sort of
ongoing the adage that you know and I
don't know whether it's African or
Chinese maybe both meeting for a day so
I wanted to be part of the latter and I
think so both to me but also to a signal
to our Haitian colleagues Yael Gordon is
not going to be with us for all this
time and my hope is that they would say
ok we better make very good use of him
and tell us what not to do because we're
wasting their time and tell us what to
do where we can be helpful and back to
your one of your earlier questions
whether being where there were being
successful at that I don't know I am
gonna stick to my promise of ending in
five years so we can do five years so
two more Springs then we'll
a sixth year we will try to do the
evaluation so we'll try to you can have
me back in three more years
okay what about some of the some of the
surprises are some of the challenges you
didn't anticipate going over there with
graduate students well many of our
graduate students at Yale but especially
in public health and at the school for
environmental studies are sort of global
world travelers already lots of Peace
Corps volunteers lots of most of the
students graduate students at Yale now
have been out three or four or five
years before they come to school so they
have real-world experience and we really
can think of them as adults or maybe
young adults but very mature and so you
I knew from the beginning I wouldn't
have to do much hand holding the the
trickiest thing for them is they're used
to traveling as independent you know in
the Peace Corps they're off on their own
here they're traveling as a team they're
part of a delegation or a consulting
firm and it takes them a little while to
figure out how to work cooperatively and
take care of each other well that's I
think that's a good life lesson to learn
to work as a team and collaborate so I
think that's a good thing that's coming
out of the class yep yep welcome but
unsurprising thing is of course that
generosity generosity of the people were
that are hosting us and we're visiting I
think if you go anywhere in the world
when you talk to probably a lot of
people you've talked to they've always
come you know I've been treated so well
I get taken so capable people care so
much about me the food is delicious
if anything I think we get embarrassed
by that in Haiti because so many of the
people that were interacting with do not
have a lot of food they may be going
from out they may be in a family where
there's one meal a day and here we are
we're getting three meals a day our
portions are probably bigger than their
so we're eating one meal then they're
eating in a horrible way right yeah so
that that's um that's hard and this I'm
used to that now and I sort of take
smaller portions and I try to not be too
hungry
but the students are you know they're
they're glad to and that and the food is
so good that you eat it up and you go
back for seconds and so seconds are sort
of a very rude phenomenon I think but
okay so you know generally speaking
since you've you've been to Haiti so
often you know what do you think needs
to happen to really move the country
forward well you're asking big questions
here the of the topics that I've thought
of the one that I'm most focused on is
self-reliance mm-hm
so I'm really interested in promoting or
asking questions or seeing where the
Haitian people individuals or groups of
individuals can sort of figure out what
they want to get done and do it for
themselves and it's it's one thing for
ask for have to ask for help for
something you want to be helped it's
another thing to get help where somebody
else thinks they know right what's good
for you so I think the more that the
culture either at the government level
or at the individual level can figure
out what he or she or anything aggregate
they need and then can go solicit that
help from the UN the United States Cuba
whatever their allies gonna be or
partners going to be in this I think
that's that's where success and it'll
take it'll be slower maybe you know the
adage there's no silver bullet this is
sort of admitting there's no silver
bullets there gonna be lots of small
steps and and moving forward one of one
topic that I find fascinating is the
history of Haiti is that it was a slave
colony under the French and the slaves
fought the revolution so in in late
1700s early 1800s which is not far after
our
American Revolution here in the United
States but our Revolution was not fought
by slaves so there is a particular
there's a peculiar or particular
ambiance or understanding that I'm I
don't think I'm ever going to be able to
understand but I know it's important to
understand that the way independence was
set up was by the slaves overthrowing
the master and that still is affecting
the culture I believe so again by the
self-reliance one of the reasons I come
to self-reliance is I think the
self-reliance is a way that a slave and
enslaved people can prove to themselves
and prove to others that they're not
enslaved anymore that they've done this
themselves and even though it's a
hundred and some years later after the
Revolution because of the history
especially the relationships the United
States which have been not very good
over many years I think that this is a
very positive set of psychological
benefit but this is a person who doesn't
know a lot about Haiti talking about
other people so we academics know that
sort of a dangerous thing to do so you'd
have to ask some Haitian people I think
what they think is the next steps well
it sounds like you're doing good things
there and I thank you for being here
today and I will look forward to having
you back to wrap up thank you for having
me that's my pleasure for more
information about Professor jabal and
his work please visit our website at
Yale edu slash McMillan report be sure
to join us again for another episode of
the McMillan report made possible by the
Whitney and Betty McMillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
thank you very much thanks so it's great
so are there any things that you don't
get a chance to do while you're there
you